my name is Peter to see much wits and i
was born in 1972 in uman up up north
greenland and i lived there of the first
12 years of my life with my parents and
and three elder sisters me and my mom
when the fishing every day we have this
in danish they call them you know
directly translated they're called long
lines I don't know what they call it in
English it's a long line with the with a
lot of hooks on and you put our way down
and the slider a big metal thing with
that with a rock on and then you slide
it under the eyes like this stretching
out the hooks on the bottom and the last
you drop a weight and then you have all
the hooks you know 100 hoaxer more way
down at the bottom fishing halibut and
those fish sure went for the dogs and
fought for ourselves so every day me and
my mom in wintertime almost every day me
and my mom women went out and got these
long lines and we arrived out at the
site and chopping the hole up again
which has frozen north during the night
or the the two nights depending on how
many days we we didn't we didn't go get
it and and then we switched you know I
started off by walking around 100 meters
and then my mom took over and you
straits out the the long line you know
and the sun is shining the talks are
waiting what more could you ask off and
did your family have a dog team or yeah
we did have a dog seen the locals
brought us a female dog or what do you
call it there and with the worst that
this is the one that's going to make the
pack for you when it's grown up and and
can give birth to it's a cuddlings or
what you call it so so and this dog came
in a bag this little female dog you know
nearly born with a 6-8 weeks old and it
was
busia with cysts back in 84 there was
this no nuke Championships of electric
boogie and breakdowns and we were
arriving here in logan i think it was
August or something july you know June
July August or something and I if I
don't remember wrong it was October or
something that these championships were
held and you know after just staying
here in New for a couple of months I was
actually in on the championships so I'm
at the hip hop culture right away and
mingled with it and started dancing as
the first part of it and from there I
moved on to DJing and a little graffiti
most mostly on paper but I'm not the big
painter so that's not my strong side I
got a big mouth and a lot of words
coming out of it so I ended up writing
lyrics after I think it was the rhythms
and and the flow of the rap and stuff
like that and then the message came with
Grandmaster Flash and and then it took a
turn and I noticed what what could be
done with with music and especially
wrapped that is I think it's more like
some of the most direct form of of
communicating through music if you
should pick a shower so rabbits directly
to the listener you know and Anna listen
to say oh that's rap music you somehow
know that this person is talking about
personal experience because that's what
Revis usually do of course you've got
the mainstream who was to make money on
clubs rags and stuff like that and it's
you know but it's it's a strong
communication form and
and I think that's what's thought to me
and and kept me at at the rap scene and
you know I kept the interest for hip hop
when we started off with new Posse it
was more like the interest of hip hop
that kept us together you know we like
this hip hop we came from from different
social backgrounds and from all social
levels so and and the thing that kept it
together was the gloom was hip hop you
know because we were quite different if
if if I can say but what we got along
great and we made these first
greenlandic rap tracks and and that was
fun
living hard as I did with too much
alcohol and too much hashish for several
years you know and not that it from day
one that I took my first pair went down
crazy but you know over the years it
went into too much drinking and too much
smoking and too much stock darkness in
my life you know and through all these
years of heavy drinking and smoking and
imparting not that it was all bad there
was many many funny parties and
somewhere somewhere along the way but it
turned bad for me you know it wasn't
good for me anymore and it took some
time to reach the point that I had to to
do something about it it was my my
partner in life that that said some
things to me you know we reached autumn
and she was lecturing me like I was a
little bite was like a teacher or mother
talking to you know I I was I had enough
I had no more lies I had I couldn't I
couldn't accuse anybody else but myself
you know I've been trying to accuse
everybody else for my heavy drinking and
living as I did but you know it was it
was me taking the beer of it was me
smoking so it ended up with me with the
help of my my life partner and and I was
the point that I had to go into rehab
and I went into rehab it was hearing up
here in Nuuk for nine weeks for alcohol
and hashish abuse and these years of
living heart and and not being so good
to my self gave me a lot of other stuff
you know I saw some things that i could
sell about hmm like what like the dark
sites of Greenland if you could call it
that you
of the social the social aspect the
social problems and tell us about some
of the social problems in Greenland
alcohol of course and and this whole
step from from from hunting culture you
know fishing hunting culture to to this
industrial interest you know what do you
call it industrialization or what of
Greenland of Greenland you know we went
through this in 10 50 years you know
from hunters to to to this working on
land and taking education and not living
by the have the nature you know let the
nature the nature forces to side but now
you have to wake up and get to school
and get to work so this process has been
very short I think compared to other
other countries developing you know this
development was Greenland went through
this for in a very short time and that
created people not getting educated you
know groups of people not being educated
and not getting an education and and
that created social losers if you should
if you can call it that you know social
what you call it social outcasts yeah
you know so and you know we got the
suicide because people maybe not feeling
worth anything because they don't have
an education you know this whole switch
has made a llama you know in the back in
the day see the husband the hunter was
you know important and they couldn't
live without him and now you have this
this educating people and and it was
mostly ladies
and the men you know couldn't find his
place somehow I think you know where do
I belong now so the development of the
country the short period of time that
that the development from hunting to so
today has been going through as had
costs on people on you know having
problem with alcohol and suicide and an
alcohol bring in all sorts of other
stuff you know I've used and abused you
know sex abuse and raping and also all
that stuff comes with the alcohol and so
it's a big bad cocktail that it brought
but then again I think it's important
where we are standing now in time that
that we accept these problems as they
are and face them and not trying to
cover up and say that no it's not like
that it's people have a children not
starving in Greenland and let's face
them and you know what country doesn't
have problems
you can make sense for some people and
maybe get them to take a little shorter
way through to this point where I'm at
in my life you know thinking of all that
the alcohol and stuff like that if i can
make someone's roads shorter from you
know through all this darkness it's it's
it's all the work worth it and then
otherwise it's still worth it because it
helped me again zuma figure you up to an
IV you and the Greenlandic language is
this is pretty strong and think it's
very powerful in expressing yourself you
can you can paint the endings of a word
and make it much more stronger or much
more said a much more angry or you know
it's it's it's a powerful language and
I'm so grateful for for being able to to
speak it not I know I can be become even
even better of speaking greenlandic but
I'm so grateful for having
so elders are of importance I think and
and they can help us with finding our
identity because they can tell about the
good old days if you can call it but you
know about Greenland from back in the
days because we still have people
remembering when they were living off
hunting you know I know this 73 year old
guy who his first memory is the sound of
water and he opens his eyes and see all
these women growing in the Umi up you
know his first memory and wow that's the
story in you know that's 11 little
strawberry and that moves me that we
have people remembering stuff like that
and you know I need I need 24 more hours
a day because there are so what's to do
here in life and so many stories to hear
and to look for and so and can you talk
to us a little bit about a project you
have in mind involving rappers from
different parts of the Arctic well I
went to the Arctic winter games in
Yellowknife as a part of cultural crew I
was like technician on a on a dance
theatre show 15 minutes show that we
prepared here in nook and being over
there well I brought my own CD to begin
with and I was thinking I want to spread
this out in the Arctic if I can knowing
that I was going to meet all these
people from the Arctic I was thinking
this is a good shot for me to just break
my word and in
just I don't know what I wanted with
this but it feels good knowing that my
words are all the way around the Arctic
somehow you know it means something for
me I don't know if it means something
something for for anybody else but I
like the feeling we were living all
these cultural acts from all the
countries at the Winter Games were
living together at this school so we had
great hours at evening with guitars and
with the traditional drum and the fiddle
and me beat boxing and and I noticed
some of the i can remember if it was no
never gonna know what but some of the
participants were i could hear them down
the hallway trying to grab a little and
and and it was in their in their own
language but i don't know which who
these guys were but and then you know
why not make a an oxy kpop event and
hopefully we can we can do something
about it I don't know if it should be
here on Canada where it could be nice to
have it here in New click weekend and
but then again it's it's it might take
some years before I I crap that idea and
do something about it otherwise anybody
up there here's this feel free to me to
work on it and
I'll be getzel to be alone